I'm having to be here to honor these
composers and nurses who have been
singled out for recognition this year to
refresh your memories here are the
nominees for original song from The Lion
King can you feel the love tonight music
by Elton John lyrics by Tim Rice from
The Lion King circle of life Elton John
lyrics by Tim Rice from The Lion King
Hakuna Matata music by Elton John lyrics
by Tim Rice from jr. look what love is
done music and lyrics by Carole Bayer
Sager James Newton Howard James Ingram
and Patty Smyth from the paper make up
your mind music and lyrics by Randy
Newman and the winner of the Oscar is
Elton John and Tim Rice can you feel the
love tonight
many thanks to everyone at Disney and in
particular as it's a musical thing mr.
Hans Zimmer but also like to thank
Dennis Compton a childhood hero of mine
over - thank you very much this is such
an exciting night I'd like to thank the
members of the Academy for this
incredible honor - - Hans Zimmer who did
a wonderful job with the songs to
everybody at Disney - my parents who are
here tonight - David - John Reed - my
friends in Utah and everyone who worked
on this most enjoyable project this is
an incredible honor for me I'd like to
dedicate this award to my grandmother
Ivy Sol she died last week and she was
the one that sat me down at the piano
when I was three and made me play so I'm
accepting this in her honor thank you
very much